[Music]  it's gender equality week the european  parliament is fighting to improve gender  equality in all policy areas five ending  gender-based violence  improving work-life balance  eliminating the gender pay-down  promoting equal access to leadership  positions  improving access to sexual and  reproductive health  empowering women especially in  technology science and research  advancing women's rights in third  countries  [Music]  making gender budgeting a reality  ensuring gender balance in all eu  institutions and beyond  everyone regardless of gender should be  treated equally and get the same  opportunities  [Music]